well hello guys hey we're back we're
back on the zoom here back on the serum
I hope nobody's favorite last one
hopefully the last one should be back in
studio next week here's hoping we got to
see it for negative all that stuff
what what's new oh you know just living
the life here now again tested today
hopefully comes out negative because
I've had no symptoms for some time now
that's good yeah I cannot say the same
for myself not feeling good I know well
I feel a saying there's nothing changes
so that's you know but you talk to
doctors and they're like yeah you know
this one doctor I know had it for three
weeks and I know the guy had terribly
bad for two weeks and was just like it
is what it is
it just manifests itself differently and
everybody I think you know the one thing
you're older - you know retired well
that's because my [ __ ] eyes have
these these circles and I don't know if
that's from the operation but it's not
going away that bothers me losing their
bruising yeah there was but it should be
gone by now but then I guess cope it
doesn't [ __ ] helps yeah how are you
guys
[Music]
chin you got yours back not yet but I
feel better so that's good so far
everybody that we have come into contact
with from what I've got coming to
contact was tested negative good
some twice same same kids I 100 cough
papa
top it woke me up last night it's a very
strange thing cuz it just lingers and it
does to you what it wants you're gonna
you're gonna [ __ ] you're on coke
let's train and covert is doing what
[ __ ] you just kind of you're at the
altar of Cobra you do what the [ __ ] he
says and that's the way it is
so you're just so wet out affected by
thing you know I know I'm a little
younger but I started that hydro cork
queen right away right that right away I
started I bees right away I get a lot of
Sun oh yeah I've been trying to do that
too but I didn't do the hydrochloric
wine because I was I should have done it
when you did it earlier but I wasn't
told to do it so I asked a couple
doctors they said don't dumb right now I
was like but it seems that whatever you
were doing with IP trips and really help
well you never really had a cost issue
never had a cough yeah see I got a call
from me mealy no no so again there's no
way every time I talk to any doctor they
kind of shake their head and go you know
they don't know
no just is weird for different people
so yeah I'll tell you this right now
yeah yeah yeah yeah watch your tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you've
been doing
[Laughter]